Today we're going to be talking
about being a British colonist,
which means we're going to be discussing
how you would feel if you were part of
the British empire in
the mid 18th century,
living in the North American
colonies shortly before the
onset of the revolution.
And for those of you who were not here
on Tuesday, I talked for a little while,
I'll just mention it here.
Um,
about how this course was really going
to be exploring the mindset of the people
who are experiencing the revolution to
really try to get it the logic behind
both what the British colonists in the
British authorities were doing and how
that ultimately resulted in a war.
So we really were going to try to really
kind of create two opposing forms of
logic and understand how they came to
oppose each other and how that ended up
leading into conflict. So it makes
sense that as a starting point,
we're going to start by
essentially talking about
some of the basics about being
a British colonist in North America.
What their world would have been like.
What your world would have been
like if you had been a colonist,
what your feelings would have been about
yourself as part of the British empire
if you were a colonist in the
middle of the 18th century.
Now I'll note here just
in passing, um, that the,
the first part of Gordon Woods radicalism,
which I already mentioned once,
that actually deals a lot with the topic
that I'll be talking about today. And,
and I think one or two more lectures,
the sort of idea about what the colonies
were like prior to the revolution.
That book overall presents
an argument about how, uh,
the colonies went from monarchy.
The first third of the book is monarchy.
And then the second,
third of the book is republicanism.
And then the third is democracy. Um,
and I think I said Tuesday, I said,
think about what words mean. I'm sure
that will come into play in Gordon Wood.
But,
um,
the monarchy section not surprisingly
goes into some depth about some of the
things I'm going to be talking
about today and on Tuesday,
which is kind of life in
the colonies before the war.
Sort of just basically what did it mean?
How did it work?
How did society function? Okay, so let's
actually start with some of the basics.
First and most basic,
if you were a British colonist
here in North America,
you would be living somewhere
along the Atlantic seaboard.
The colonial population was largely
clustered right along the shoreline.
It's for really practical reasons.
I'm sure you don't have to be
very imaginative to think why.
I'm obviously for reasons of trade,
for reasons of shipping,
and even just for reasons of
communication. It made sense.
Not to mention the fact that people had
a pretty healthy fear of potentially
unfriendly Indians who were
not particularly pleased
with the idea of losing
land to potentially advancing settlers.
Now,
if you were male,
you might very well be a small landholder
because about 60% of the white male
colonists owned land.
And as I'll talk about
down the road a little bit,
that's actually when you compare that
with the rates of land ownership and
Europe, that's actually pretty high.
It's pretty high rate of ownership.
And even in today's lecture you'll see
how that actually has an impact on how
things are functioning in
the American colonies. Um,
you probably would be a small landholder
you met might be if you were living in
one of the small cities along the coast,
maybe a merchant or an artisan
as a non enslaved person,
you would probably have decent clothes.
You probably have a decent home.
You probably would have some degree of
economic and personal independence and
right around the term like let's say 1770,
you would be one of about 2 million North
American colonists, which is actually,
if you think about it,
certainly if you,
if I asked you to guess how many
colonists there, we're in 1770.
You probably would not say
2 million. It's a lot. Um,
and that includes both
free people and slaves.
And you would have been
living in a society that was
so booming with prosperity
that between the year 1,717 70 so we're
just talking about a 70 year period.
The population increased from 200,000
to over 2 million in just a 70 year
period,
which is amazing.
So basically things were
increasing every decade.
The population was increasing at a rate
of roughly 30 to 40% it's a huge rate of
growth. You would be living in the
midst of a host of British colony.
So it's not just you along the seaboard,
but obviously to the north.
There's Canada to the south,
there were British islands
in the West indies,
which were known as the sugar islands.
And to the West was the vast scary
wilderness populated by potentially
unfriendly Indians with what felt to
you as though it was an entirely foreign
culture. And then of course
to the east, to the east,
there is civilization to your east. There
is the metropolis, there is England,
there is culture in the minds of the
colonists and probably to many people in
England as well,
the height of cultural and
political sophistication
when you looked to the east.
And it really was,
if you were a colonist,
it was looking to the
east towards England,
that you really got a sense of yourself
as a British colonist and really felt
that you belong to something that was
powerful and admirable and world shaping
and victorious basically,
you understood yourself as being part
of an empire by identifying with that
center of Empire to the east.
As an example of this,
just listen to someone who ends up
being a rather prominent American
revolutionary.
And I mentioned him as a matter of fact.
On Tuesday I called him to the doctor,
to the stars,
and that's kind of unfair to
him. Um, but Benjamin Rush,
he actually was a really prominent
man of science at the time.
He moved in very high political circles.
Um,
when I was thinking about this
lecture today, I remembered,
or at least I hope I remembered, I
think I'm not leading you astray. Um,
I think that that actually
rush help Thomas Paine edit
common sense and I think,
uh, he edited out a sentence
that I wished pain had left in.
So I don't like Russia as an
editor very much. I think,
well wait till we get to common sense,
but,
and supposedly allegedly it's rush who
came up with the title common sense that
pain was going to call it plain truth and
a rushed. I think rush wounds on that.
I think plain truth is not as snazzy
as is common sense, but either way. Um,
so rush the,
the,
my main point here in blathering happily
about rush is he's not some little
modest humbug of a guy,
right? He's someone of status.
So this is Russia's response when he
saw the throne of the King of England.
So rush said,
I felt as though I were on sacred ground.
I gaze for some time at the throne with
emotions that I cannot describe. Okay.
He's, he's just dumbstruck at the
throne of the King of England.
Just looking at it now we sit here,
we think back were like,
oh boy,
aren't those monarchists really cute.
It was cute water cause was silly.
People who are amazed at a throne,
which is pretty much I think
what I thought was wow,
what an interesting phase in
American history when they
were dazzled by a throne.
Then a couple of years ago I ended up
being lucky enough to have a member of
parliament show me around the houses
of parliament and I was excited.
It's pretty neat being all American
historian ish, you know. Oh, how similar.
How interesting. When you compare it. So
I'm doing the geeky storing thing and uh,
then this,
this member of parliament who's
showing me around takes me into what he
described to me as the roping
chamber for the Queen, uh,
where she puts on her crown and ceremonial
robes before she goes into the House
of Lords,
which I gather she does at the beginning
of every session of parliament. Okay.
So I'm walking to like the robbing
chamber and at the head of that room,
there's a throne,
sort of an elevated throne.
So like instantly without even
thinking in my head, I'm thinking, wow,
like that's the throne.
And then I thought I just
became Benjamin Rush. Like,
like just like that.
I went right into the monarchy vortex.
Like it didn't really take me very long,
so I can't chortle at rush anymore.
So there is something
impressive and particularly
at this moment if you had been
a colonist,
um,
and not that many people I should say
necessarily even got to travel to Europe.
I'll talk a little bit
about that later on too.
But you certainly would have been Austrac
and impressed by something like the
throne of the King of England.
Okay.
So as suggested by rush quavering in
front of the throne as a colonist,
you would be proud to be British.
You would have a really deep affection
for the mother country and it would be an
affection that was really rooted in bonds
of culture and tradition and language.
Basically,
you would really consider yourself lucky
to belong to a powerful nation that
granted its citizens.
You believed more liberty than any
nation on unlike other modern empires.
At the time,
England seemed particularly to the
English to be an empire that was bound
together,
not by force,
but by bonds of interconnectedness
and affection as well as a joint
appreciation,
real love of liberty and order.
And we're going to come back to this
idea of liberty a little bit later in the
course where we start to really
talk about the logic of revolution.
But for now I'll just highlight the fact
that if you asked an English speaking
person of the 18th century about liberty,
he or she would have told you that
liberty was worth more than life, right?
Liberty was it.
Liberty was what mattered.
It was the most important
possession of a civilized people.
And of course the British people,
colonists and all felt that they were
at the peak of the civilized world.
As somebody at the time
wrote what signify riches?
What signifies health or
life itself without liberty?
Wife without liberty is
the most errant trifle,
the most insignificant
enjoyment in the world. Okay.
Extreme.
But you know something to think about.
I suppose it's related to what I said.
I'm on Tuesday.
I think it's also easy to hear some of
this talk that sounds really inflated and
to dismiss it as mere rhetoric.
Um,
and I'm sure there is some mere
rhetoric floating around here,
but it's important,
I think,
not to dismiss things that sound extreme
and emotional as simply emotional and
extreme. I mean, some of this
actually represents sincere thought.
So I think before you think these guys
are sort of over excited about things,
think here's off that they actually
honestly may be over excited.
It might just be that they're dramatic,
but that they sincerely feel these things.
There was a time when
historians did assume that a
lot of revolutionary rhetoric
from the colonists was
actually kind of inflated,
kind of for propaganda purposes. Um,
and it took a while actually, um,
the faces of revolution book by Bailyn
at part of the book that I mentioned
before, it comes from his larger book
on the ideology of the revolution.
He's the guy who said,
you know,
I've read several hundred revolutionary
war pamphlets and I actually think
they're serious.
I think we have to take them seriously.
I don't think it's propaganda or rhetoric.
I think they actually feel these things.
So again,
to us it might sound a little inflated,
but their feelings are really strong. And,
and again,
liberty is one of the things that we'll
find they're feeling very strongly about.
So as a colonist,
you would be proud to be British.
You would be really obviously proud of
British liberties and you would have been
particularly proud about being British
after the French and Indian war in the
1760s when North American colonists fought
right alongside the British army and
helped them defeat England's great enemy,
the French,
and more on that to come for sure.
But that was a really proud
moment for the colonists,
that they felt that they were right there
with the British army fighting against
the French above all else.
As British colonists,
you would of course,
consider yourselves to be British
subjects through and through equal to all
other British subjects. Even those living
off in the east, in the metropolis,
you were a British subject and you
deserve the rights of a British subject.
But as a colonist living
on the peripheries of the
British empire on the edge of
what was perceived at the time
to be a howling wilderness,
which is one of those great 18th century
ways of referring to North America. Um,
you also would be a little nervous
about your status as a British subject,
worried about how you rated in comparison
with people living in the mother
country at the center of the empire.
Everything seemed more sophisticated
in England and I suppose everything was
more sophisticated in England,
but it definitely seemed
that way to the colonists.
The clothes were more fashionable,
the homes were grander and more stately.
The intellectual life was rich and
challenging in comparison with the
sophisticated people in England.
You as a North American colonists
pretty much felt like a country bumpkin.
You felt kind of dull, kind
of primitive, somewhat rude,
and certainly you felt
potentially irrelevant.
You really did feel that you are on
the edge of a howling wilderness.
So in essence, like most British
colonists in North America,
if you were there at the time, you would
have had an ongoing inferiority complex.
Now,
there were a number of ways in which
you might deal with your insecurities.
Um,
one way to deal with that would have
been to become really apologetic for what
would have been labeled as American
speech patterns or American manners.
And I've already given you one
arrogant British quote, um,
by that fellow on Tuesday who said
that he was mortified that these crude
colonists spoke English.
I can trace themselves to us
because they speak our language.
So it's sort of the ultimate
nasty stab at the colonists.
So you actually for good reason might
feel kind of embarrassed about your
manners and your speech.
You probably would feel
equally embarrassed at the
meanness of your architecture.
Your buildings are smaller and less
impressive at the pallor of your
intellectual life at the relative
unimportance of your public affairs.
Like a lot of colonial writers who
wrote pamphlets or books addressed to an
English audience,
you probably would apologize for the
poor quality of your work by reminding
readers as one writer did.
I live in the uncultivated
woods of America,
far from the fountains of science and
with but very rare opportunities of
conversing with learned men.
That's almost sounds like someone feels
sorry for himself and I'm so far from
civilization or you might boast about
colonial society not claiming to be better
than the mother country,
but instead bragging that the colonies
represented in miniature that colonial
legislatures.
In this sense,
we're kind of like mini parliaments or
you might admit that the colonies were
different from England,
but boast that in the same way that
England once had been pure and virtuous,
you in the colonies were maintaining the
sort of pure virtuous England and that
England itself was becoming corrupt and
it's cities were becoming cesspools,
but they are in the colonies.
You are preserving the true
British heritage still.
Whichever way you chose to rationalize
or understand your status as a colonist,
you could not escape the fact that you
were a colonist and that you were far
away from the center of the civilized
world as the young John Dickinson of
Pennsylvania put it. And we're going
to meet John Dickinson again for sure.
Later on to the course.
Uh,
he wrote to his father while
he was studying law in London,
and he said that when colonists went to
England and saw the difference between
themselves and the polite part of the
world, they must be miserable. I mean,
he actually thinks of people,
any colonists goes to London and sees
what the polite part of the world lives.
Like. They'll never be able to hold
their head up in the colonies ever again.
And Jefferson felt the same way.
Thomas Jefferson actually, um,
as much as he adored being,
uh, particularly in France. Um,
he actually said more than once that he
thought that young American men should
not be allowed to go to Europe because
if they impressionable young men went to
Europe,
they would be so impressed by Paris and
London that they would never be able to
hold their heads up in
Massachusetts or Virginia.
It would look so puny and insignificant
in comparison that they would never be
good Americans ever again and that
they'd have to go back to Europe.
Now,
of course,
the British agreed generally with
this assessment of colonial society,
colonists obviously were inferior
and rough and rustic and crude.
So as promised,
here is yet another arrogant British
quote in my series of arrogant British
quotes. Um, in this case,
one British observer noted
American colonists may try
to ape British habits and
customs, but they're no more than
ruffled dunces. I just think there's,
these guys have like a real vim and
vigor for finding like the little zippy
stinging ft statement. I think
ruffled dunces is a pretty good one.
What else could be expected
from aggrandized upstarts
in those infant countries
of America who never have an opportunity
to see or if they had the opportunity
to observe the different ranks
of men in polite nations.
Notice how the colonies are never polite.
They're the polite missions.
And then there's the scary
howling wilderness colonists.
Along these same lines,
there's actually another professor
here at gale Kerrianne Yakota. Um,
and some of her work shows I found
this really fascinating. Um, the,
the British regularly sent,
um,
damaged or second rate goods
to the colonists because
they figured the colonist
wouldn't know the difference.
They just kept the first rights stuff for
themselves, like broken Massachusetts.
They'll never know last week, last
year, his style, Massachusetts.
So basically all of the shows that if
Americans had an inferiority complex,
they had some reason to have one.
Now,
let me add at this point that this
anxiety about how the colonists rated in
comparison with England,
specifically in Europe,
the polite world generally
doesn't end with the revolution.
It's not as though suddenly we,
when the revolution then we don't really
care what the rest of the world thinks
even after the colonies.
And then the states had fought and
defeated the great power of the British
empire and successfully created
a new national constitution.
Americans were still worried about looking
sophisticated enough in the eyes of
the world.
And my favorite example of this,
it's a little bit down the road from
the moment that we're at in this course,
but I just can't resist adding it in
cause it's just, it makes me happy.
And it's John Adams. Um,
and it's actually from 1789.
It's right when this new national
constitution has gone into effect.
And the Senate is debating what the
title should be for the new national
executive, right? We know there's
going to be a national executive,
we don't know what
we're going to call him.
And so the Senate is debating this
and someone in the Senate says, well,
why don't we call him president
of the United States? Okay,
this horrifies John Adams. I
mean, absolutely horrifies him.
And as he says at the
time, says, for God's sake,
they're presidents of cricket clubs,
president of the United States,
and I'll quote him exactly here.
He does say the presence of cricket clubs,
but he says in the Senate,
um, where is it here?
What will the common people
of foreign countries,
what will the sailors and soldiers say,
George Washington,
president of the United States,
they will despise him to all eternity.
I was just thinking in a world where
you have his royal highness protector of
the realm, you know, president of the
United States, he's just thinking,
there's just no comparison.
It doesn't rank.
So as we're going to be seeing in
future weeks of this course, there's a,
there's a constant thinking about what,
how we're being looked upon.
And that doesn't go away.
It shifts. It's different,
but it remains for quite some time.
America in one way or another,
always assumes they're being
watched and judged in the 1760s.
We'll see soon.
How could these sort of colonial feelings
of inferiority would help fuel the
hypersensitivity of the
colonists to infringements
on their rights by the mother
country. Now, despite all of this anxiety,
all of this inferiority complex that
I'm talking about here as a colonist,
you did share a base of assumptions
and values with your counterparts in
England. So first of
all, as an individual,
you assumed that you lived in a great
hierarchy as sort of natural order.
Everyone in his or her place different to
those that were beneath you, respected,
but I'm sorry, different to those
above you. That's a nifty order.
If you're different to those
beneath you and respected,
you would be respectful to those
above and people below you would be
differential to you.
So basically everyone is in their place
and everybody's acting respectful and
deferential as they properly should.
And this,
you'll see a lot of this and Gordon Wood.
Now of course,
the American version of
this great social order,
this great hierarchy is different in
some ways from its British equivalent
because the colonies lacked both the top,
most and the bottom most rungs of
society in England. So in the colonies,
there wasn't a titled Entrenched
Aristocracy and there wasn't an entrenched
peasant class. Instead,
the colonies had what?
Some called a middling society which
was populated mostly by either middling
folk,
logically enough who had migrated from
England to better their lot in life by
the English poor who hoped to better
themselves and by some of the lower ranks
of the English gentry like third or
fourth sons of the English gentry who
basically knew they weren't going to
inherit anything in England and so their
thought was,
well maybe if I head off to the colonies
I it'll be easier for me to get some
land there.
I'll be able to better myself.
I'll be able to basically make something
of myself there easier than I can here.
Now,
if you were thinking about going to the
colonies and if and you really want it
to get rich quick,
the West indies was the place to go though
it also offered some of the absolute
worst living conditions in
the British colonial world.
Life there was extremely hard.
There was unbearable heat.
All energies were focused on
gaining money and little else.
West Indian planters, we're so
focused on money, money, crops,
they actually didn't even
bother to grow their own food.
They imported food because
they didn't want to waste land,
energy and resources on
growing their own food.
They were really focused
on their money crop.
If you went to the nds to get rich quick,
typically you either made it big
or failed miserably and either way,
typically what happened is
he would go to the indies,
you would establish a plantation,
you would find an overseer,
you would put him in charge,
and then you would flee back to England
and be an absentee landlord and let the
people live in misery and the West indies
while you collected the profit off of
your sugar crop back home in England.
Now the indies, not surprisingly,
it might seem a little intimidating
if you wanted to get rich quick,
you might choose not to go down
to the scary sugar islands.
You might decide instead to go to the
southern colonies to get rich quick.
And for example,
it was largely sons of the lesser gentry
in who went to Jamestown at the start
of the 17th century in Virginia.
And logically enough,
since these are sons of the lesser
gentry and they consider themselves to be
above hard labor,
they show up to this rather
primitive new colony and Jamestown,
they refuse to work to,
to grow their own food
and they starve to death.
Like that's a serious commitment to your
status. I'm sorry, I'm above plowing.
I'm going to die now.
I mean,
you think sooner or later they kind of
figure a little plowing life. You know,
it's kind of, I don't
know. Um, at any rate,
there's a reason why
Jamestown didn't do so well.
And there's a great example
of this weird mentality, um,
is Nathaniel Bacon who's
a genteel colonist.
He's a younger son of a member of the
British gentry and in the 17th century,
sure enough, he migrates, he ends up
in Virginia and he arrives in Virginia.
Like a lot of people assuming
that he deserved power,
he deserved land and he deserves status.
I mean he's among the lesser gentry,
but he still is among the upper crust
and England and now he's arriving among
the rood,
ruffled bounces of the colonies.
He assumes he's someone who deserves
what he wants. Lo and behold,
he gets there and he finds that actually
in Virginia there's a kind of inner
core of men self made men who had been
there for awhile or their families had
been there for a while and basically
they controlled most of the land.
They controlled most of
the government offices.
They had most of the power and that
they could exclude bacon and others from
getting what they wanted.
Bacon,
obviously it's a person who's much more
interested in making money than in the
good of the colony.
So he responded to his frustration and
not being able to get land or power by
surrounding himself with a
pack of equally frustrated,
angry young men who also wanted
land and also wanted power.
And eventually they came up with the
brilliant idea that they would stage and
enormous attack on Indians massacred
them all and steal their land.
Brilliant plot.
So Bacon and his,
his pack of guys sort of go off
and actually start this inaction.
The governor of the colony sees that this
is rapidly spinning out of control and
becoming wild,
crazy Indian warfare.
So he tries to stifle it and Nathaniel
Bacon and his friends did what I suppose
appeared logical to them at the time
they burn Jamestown to the ground because
they were angry. But that's, I
mean, that's serious anger. Oh,
you're going to stop us. We'll just
destroy the capital. You're gone.
Now the story is kind of anti climactic
because Bacon ultimately dies miserably
of dysentery while running
away from authority.
So there's not a lot of glory
and Bacon's ultimate end. Um,
but he's definitely a really good example
of greedy self interest and have the
sense of deservedness
because of his social rank.
And this discussed at the power of
these self made men in Virginia.
There was some gentry who would've
migrated to the colonies who would've had
some kind of a similar feeling about
what they saw and what they expected.
But the gentry was only a minority of
the people who migrated to the colonies.
Most were lower in status.
Some are have the lowest rank of all
landless people and sometimes criminals.
So if you committed a crime in England,
you might be offered the option between
prison in England and being sent to the
colonies. And to some, this was actually
a really hard choice, right? Prison,
the colonies, prison, the
colonies, I don't know,
the howling wilderness was very scary.
Now some people opted for the howling
wind wilderness, obviously. Um,
and some people,
poorer people decided to take
their chances on the colonies,
sold themselves into servitude
as indentured servants
for five to seven years at
a time. And in exchange,
their passage was paid,
they owed a certain amount of work,
and at the end of their time of indenture,
they would get some plot of land.
So there were a good number of indentured
servants. And as a matter of fact,
some of those Virginia power mongers who
were blocking bacon out had started out
actually as indentured servants.
I mean that's when you talk self made and
you're really talking self made people
who came did their indenture, got some
land and then really built their way up.
So self improvement obviously is
one reason to head to the colonies.
Another reason,
another thing that might drive you to
head off to the colonies would have been
if you belong to a religious minority
that was seemingly increasingly unpopular
in England. So if you were a puritan, if
you were a Quaker, if you were Catholic,
again probably middling in status,
you might decide to try your luck in the
colonies where either you thought there
might be more religious tolerance or just
as likely there'd be lance so empty of
people that it wouldn't
really be a worry of yours.
There wouldn't be people around there
to be intolerant of views that would
probably would be better than what
you were experiencing in England.
Obviously a lot of New England was
settled by puritans with that mindset.
Pennsylvania had the Quaker
faith at its cure, at its core,
it was founded by William Penn, who is
actually a member of the aristocracy.
He became a Quaker and then he used his
high connections to get a royal charter
from the king to found a colony for
Quakers and Maryland began as a place that
was distinctly friendly to people
of the Catholic faith. Now,
out of all of these kinds of
colonists that I'm talking about here,
what was missing was a titled sort of to
the Manor born established aristocracy
of dukes and duchesses unshakably
of the highest rank in society.
This doesn't mean that colonial society
didn't have an established elite because
certainly every colony had certain great
families that controlled large amounts
of power and land, and as a
colonist, as an average colonist,
you would have had no
problem differentiating these
gentle folk from the common
masses, right? These sort of gentlemen
and gentle women, they dress differently.
They held themselves differently.
They spoke differently.
You address these people by
Mister or madam or Esquire.
I mean you actually visibly could tell
who the sort of upper crust people in
society were.
Some families held obvious power,
but again,
not in the unquestionable way that
the aristocracy remained in control in
England.
A lot of these people that
I just mentioned had worked
their way into positions
of prominence.
So ultimately the line dividing sort
of upper crusty people from less upper
crusty people was less sort of absolute.
It was less distinct than it would have
been in a country or in a place where
there was a really established
aristocracy. So basically,
even though you could tell who the elite
are and you can tell who the masses are
there slippage up and
down between the two.
It's not as though there's a dividing
line and you could never hope to become an
aristocrat. It's a little blurrier.
It's again, middling society.
It's part of what that means.
And because of that,
things like formal titles and find
clothing were of extreme importance in the
colonies and in a lot of
ways more important in the
colonies than they were in
England because they really were ways
of proving your status in a place where
you felt the need to prove your status.
If you think about it,
your status would have been just
a matter of common agreement.
You are only as lofty in status
as people believed you were.
And if someone felt compelled to call you
by a title or if you were wearing find
clothing that people knew they
themselves couldn't afford,
that could go a long way
towards convincing people of
your status and importance.
So for example,
if you had any military service at all,
even for the briefest moment you'd
served in the military and you were an
officer,
you would insist forever after to the end
of your days that you be called always
by your title like colonel
so and so, or captain. So.
And so that military
title counted for a lot.
That was really a sort of unquestioned
symbol of rank and authority. And in fact,
some people join the military just because
they knew by doing so they would get
a title and then they would be able to
hang on to that title to really claim a
place for themselves in
society. And when I was, um,
when I was researching my first
book, um, I came across, um,
a case where there are these two guys.
Sounds like a bad joke.
Two guys in a tavern. There were
these two guys in a tavern and um,
one of them is a military
officer and one of them isn't.
And I guess the guy who wasn't a military
officer wasn't so clear on the whole
rank thing and he called the fellow
by a lower rank than he was, you know,
well, captain something
instead of colonel something.
And the guy was so insulted that his
title had been lowered by who the hell was
his person that he actually challenged
him to a duel like right there, I'm sorry,
but I'm willing to kill you now.
You called the captain, you die.
The serious insult dreaden sold.
Well,
and also he might've just been crazy
person, but that's too, but still,
it actually was a serious insult because
military titles and status went hand in
hand. Sometimes strangers
who seem to be high ranking,
we're just called colonel or general
cause they seemed important and thus they
must have a military rank. Um, and
I actually found a diary of someone,
this sort of member of the South Carolina
elite and he was wandering around in
the back country. Um, and he says in
his diary, no matter where he went,
he was called curl,
which amazed him because he said not only
had he never had any military service,
but, and I don't know what this means.
I don't know enough about him to know.
But he kept saying over and over again,
I really don't look like a military
person, like nothing about me.
So I'm imagining this sort of sloppy,
scary guy who's wandering around in
the back country of South Carolina and
people were saying, Colonel Wow.
And people usually love that.
I mean this make him happy.
He wrote about it in his diary
because he liked it so much.
This made him a happy guy.
So obviously titles, status,
they are important and
they go hand in hand.
Now if you were in college in the
colonies, so if you were at Yale,
if you were at Harvard, if you were at
King's college, which is now Colombia,
these kinds of distinctions of rank and
status would have been a part of your
everyday life because
when you entered college,
you were listed as a member of your class
in the order of your social rank. Okay.
So the person at the highest social rank
is listed at the top of the class and
the person of the lowest social rank
is listed at the bottom of the class.
And at commencement ceremonies
or graduation ceremonies,
the highest in rank was the one who
got to speak the longest and give the
longest public address. And obviously
because as I've been saying things,
they're less entrenched.
What this meant was lots of really petty,
nasty squabbling at a lot of universities
because everybody had a complaint.
Well, I'm not on the bottom. Well, I
certainly have a better rank than him.
He should be at the bottom.
I should be at the,
so certainly it's a contentious issue
at colleges. And what this meant,
oddly enough,
is that when the grading system,
when people actually figured out that
you could have a grading system and base
judge people based on grades,
unbelievably,
this was seen as a great relief.
This made people really
grades and made people really,
really happy because it meant that you
could be judged based on merit and not
based on rank or it's social class.
So you can give thanks to
the democracy of grades.
Remember that during the semester
I'll, I'll, I'll remind you,
give thanks for your grades.
Okay.
So we've talked about some
of the similarities and
differences and social rank
between colonists and
people living in England.
I want to just take a few minutes
to talk about some assumptions about
government and about rights,
about individual rights.
Because one of the periods of
great migration to the colonies,
which was the mid to late 17th century,
was also a period in which parliament
asserted its dominance in England.
So while all Englishman believed in
the importance of political liberty and
legislative representation and the rule
of law and all of these things I've
started to talk about, the colonies were
full of people who either themselves,
I'd left England or were descended from
people who had left England when that
kind of belief was at an all time high.
So colonial governments embodied that
spirit to a really extreme degree.
And it's important to
realize that colonial talk of
liberty wasn't some kind of
colonial innovation.
It was the most heartfelt of British
traditions as I've suggested just in this
lecture.
And as we're going to see in future weeks,
it's the precise meaning of liberty as
translated into the colonies from England.
And as the slowly shifts over time,
it's going to help raise conflict between
the colonies and the mother country.
But questions about the precise meaning
of liberty wouldn't really become an
issue until the 1760s after the French
and Indian war when as we'll soon see the
British would end what had been a long
period of what's often called it period
of salutary neglect,
a period when the British largely he
just left the colonies alone to regulate
themselves and throughout
that period of of neglect,
colonists had lived immersed in their
sense of English rights and privileges,
unaware of the ways in which
the colonial experience,
just the experience of living in the
colonies had suddenly altered their
understanding of these rights.
They've been able to live in the back
kind of a freedom largely because of the
nature of the British
imperial administration.
Typically rather than exerting great
control over the colonization process,
the British crown tended to
leave colonization largely
to private enterprise,
so like a joint stock company would get
a grant to establish a colony and off
they go and it wasn't really necessarily
the crown that had its hand on
everything.
It was these private companies.
There were often taking care of the
colonization efforts and on the few
occasions when the crown
did pass trade regulations,
they didn't enforce them very rigorously,
which basically allowed widespread
smuggling and bribery. So in a sense,
the success of the British imperial system
up until the 1760s was largely due to
what was not really a policy,
but the absence of a policy,
right. This neglect of the
colonies by the mother country,
not until the British began to actively
regulate the colonies in the mid 18th
century did it really become apparent
that colonial and British ideas about the
role of the colonies and the rights of
colonists had really begun to drift apart.
Had the colonist forfeited some of their
English liberties by migrating to the
new world or not where they dependent
on the mother country or were they just
contributors to the greater empire?
And some colonists would come to have a
clear answer to those kinds of questions.
They would argue, and we're going
to see this in weeks to come,
and specifically people writing this
argument and offering it to the public,
that the original settlers of the
colonies had been free born subjects of
England who had left England with the
authorization of the monarchy and taking a
good,
many personal risks had created thriving
English settlements at little cost to
the English government bringing
England great riches in the process.
So essentially some colonists would
argue not only were they English,
but they made personal
sacrifices for England.
They attained a wilderness for
England for the sake of the empire.
And ironically,
it would be that mentality,
that kind of outcry for the rights of
Englishman that would help lead the
colonists to revolt against
England as we'll see. In a sense,
the colonies were never as English as
when they rebelled against the mother
country for the rights of Englishmen.
And I will stop there. Um,
Tuesday we will be looking at some things
that were distinctly American about
the colonial experience.
Have a good weekend.